das war also der vorschlag den herr
weller auch teil der von frau teuteberg
kommt auch mit in die ampel
verhandlungen mit rein und sie setzten
sich in denselben in denselben ampel
verhandlungen herr marquardt dafür ein
die
asylbewerberleistungen ja quasi zu
beerdigen und ja noch höhere leistung
noch höhere transferleistungen zu zahlen
also sie haben hier die frage ja schon
mal gestellt ich habe kann ich offen
sagen keine lust jetzt die diskussion
die wir in den koalitionsverhandlungen
darüber führen jetzt hier öffentlich zu
machen wir uns darauf geeinigt dass wir
das wirklich auch vertraulich machen
dass wir da sicherlich gute argumente
auf allen seiten haben für bestimmte
ideen dann guckt man sich an welche
perspektiven haben ja eigentlich von
einem film war bestimmt eine lösung die
werden sie auch irgendwann erfahren aber
ich wollte nur sagen die frage der
sozialleistung ich weiß ihn ist die
offenbar wichtig sie fragen wir einige
male schon nach ja es ist eigentlich
dieser sendung wird er sich noch in
dieser saison und sie haben ja gefragt
ob ich das irgendwie für besonders
wichtiges thema halte oder soda glaube
dass der hauptgrund dass die leute
kommen kann ich mit nein beantworten
aber auch gesagt dass ich glaube dass
der griechische migrationsminister sie
haben politiker vielleicht auch nicht so
offen darüber redet was er sonst noch
für dinge besser machen könnte es ist ja
wirklich absurd und da bin ich bei
handballer das in griechenland offenbar
die mindeststandards in den lagern nicht
gelten dass griechenland relativ viel
geld dafür bekommt das eigentlich besser
hinzubekommen und dass griechenland dann
am ende eigentlich hauptsächlich
versucht eine situation zu schaffen in
der die menschen die auch anerkannt sind
anerkannte flüchtlinge in griechenland
keine perspektive in griechenland haben
sondern denkt man ihn ausweist denn das
ist aber genau das muss das müsste man
vielleicht auch noch mal fragen ich habe
das ganze interview heute werden sie
hergestellt in dem interview zu
interview gibt es auf bild.de zu sehen
nur ist das in fantasie frage der senior
spannender ist dass sie dafür nicht
zuständig sind das ist schon für sie
spannendere dass das nämlich die
hausaufgabe vom griechischen
migrationsminister jahren ist ihre allem
hausaufgabe lass uns über eine
hausaufgabe sprechen herr marquardt die
obergrenze gilt die eigentlich aktuell
wenn wir darüber sprechen wie groß unser
aufnahmevermögen und zwar
aufnahmebereitschaft noch ist der tigers
hat das genannt herr müller hat das auch
genannt also gilt diese obergrenze für
sie fort in der künftigen regierung also
ich habe ja gesagt dass wir sozusagen
jetzt nicht mehr suchen einen
koalitionsvertrag vorzulesen den es noch
nicht gibt aber die frage war wirklich
ein bisschen weil es gab ja keine
obergrenze wir haben schon 2017 als die
diskussion anfliegen die kammern
maßgeblich vom späteren innenminister
seehofer dann ist der obergrenze von
200.000 wortgenau ja und da wurde auch
festgelegt im koalitionsvertrag der
großen koalition das ist eben keine
obergrenze gibt sondern dass die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention gilt also die
menschen die dann ein asylantrag stellen
wollen und das ist ja die frage um die
es geht die köln in einem
rechtsstaatlichen verfahren daran und da
haben sie uns an recht drauf
herausfinden das sollte man natürlich
human und effizient machen wer hat
eigentlich einen schutzstatus verdient
wäre kein schutz starke gefährt andere
gründe das ist ein super frage dann
total wichtig die frage ist wirklich und
das ist dass es muss man sagen in der
tat eine wichtige frage und da stellt
ein das asylrecht die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention vor
herausforderungen auch relativ bewusst
nach den erfahrungen aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg dass man eben dort nicht
sofort alles recht kontingentiert
sondern dass man sagt wir geben der
staatengemeinschaft den auftrag auch für
die welt zu sorgen in der eben nicht
einfach wäre fluchtbewegung stattfinden
und da fand ich dass wir relativ viel
jetzt über europa geredet haben haben
über deutschland geredet alles wichtig
aber was ich mir wünschen würde bei der
frage belarus zum beispiel ist dass
jemand die bundesminister horst seehofer
oder heiko maas eben dann auch mal in
den irak fährt und versucht vor ort zu
klären wie es denn sein kann dass so
viele menschen dann sich dort auf den
weg machen wie man verhandeln kann das
nicht eher in der logischen reise alles
passiert hat noch keine erfolge gezeigt
bisher diese obergrenze die herr
marquardt nicht so nennen möchte diesen
korridor von 180 bis 220 tausend der bei
ungefähr 200.000 egal was kommt ich
bitte was das praktisch wenn man tut
dann immer so aber denn jetzt millionen
kommen und das ist natürlich eine gute
überschrift in der bild zeitung aber das
ist nicht die realität ist doch gar
nichts mit dem millionen leute und das
immer mit 2000 das hat ja gesagt außer
wenn das relative europol ist es hat ja
keiner real und neue flüchtlingskrise
haben die eingangshalle flüchtlingskrise
und das bestätigt die bundespolizei das
bestätigen ganz viele praktika vor ort
und die menschen dort in guben und in
görlitz und eisenhüttenstadt die das im
moment aushalten müssen seither steht
die bestätigung genau das und die wollen
wissen wie viele kommende noch und
deswegen sind sie auch so interessiert
an der zahl